débat de boot des pastilles à des
briques ou encore des pâtisseries
orientales dans ce restaurant à montigny
le bretonneux la vente à emporter est un
succès avec plus d'une vingtaine de
clients parmi 10 oui ça marche bien et
puis ça permet aussi de garder un
certain lien avec les clients qui
pendant confinement ne voyais pas trop
de personnes et puis ça leur permet
d'avoir un commerce de proximité
selon les propriétaires la fréquentation
s'explique par l'emplacement de
l'établissement situé dans l'espace
saint quentin à montigny le bretonneux
on a des échos la gagnent ou qu'ils sont
pas très bien placé là on arrive à
capter un certain flux on a des
personnes qui habitent sur place et on a
aussi des personnes qui travaillent sur
place
on a des boutiques qui sont encore qui
sont fermées aux clients mais qui
travaillent en click and collect donc
ils sont sur place et c'est aussi pour
eux une solution le midi parce que si
tout est fermé ils ont pas non plus de
quoi se restaurer à quelques kilomètres
de là dans cet autre restaurant à
montigny le bretonneux cette
restauratrice a perdu de nombreux
clients la vente à emporter ne séduit
pas ce jeudi midi là seulement six
clients sont venus un bon midi comparé à
d'autres c'est pas pareil comme le
premier confinement on travaille
beaucoup beaucoup moins même il ya deux
jours on travaille pas du tout et
c'est très dur on a le loyer on a on a
tous je charges fixes on a on a pas mal
de choses à payer oui ça va être très
très très dur
heureusement la gérante du restaurant
peut compter sur ses clients fidèles qui
habitent à proximité de l'établissement
avec le confinement je sais que c'est
pas facile et où je me dis c'est un
moyen de soutenir les commerçants de
proximité même avec peu de clients la
restauratrice travail de 8 heures à 22
heures pour elle pas question de
fermeture
les aides de l'état devrait arriver
d'ici là pour payer notamment les
charges fixes des restaurateurs
[Musique]